In this part of our presentation, I'd like to talk about Unreal Motion Graphics, or UMG for short.
Now, UMG is a tool that's used to create both the visuals and the functional part of any type of UI you wish to display.
Now, UI can include anything from menus, whether those are full screen menus or pop-up menus, to HUDs or heads-up display.
These are going to be things that convey information such as maybe the speed of a car or the health of a user,
or even 3D info. So this might be if you walk up to maybe a computer and you press a button.
You can even use UMG to create the buttons that you interact with.
Now, this tool, UMG, is actually a combination of two different tools.
There is the Designer, which I like to affectionately refer to as the tool where we make things pretty.
This is where we do things like add buttons and set up where those buttons will be positioned on the screen.
Then, inside of our event graph, this is where we make things functional.
So we have all these beautiful buttons. This is where we actually program what those buttons do when they're clicked on.
So let's pop over to the editor really quick and have a look at this.
Now, here's our standard UMG widget, and again, here I have the Designer and the Graph.
So let's take a look at the Designer's areas a little more closely.
So over here in the palette, this is where we're going to find things that we want, such as buttons, scroll bars,
slide bars, loading bars, all of that stuff.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to take this button.
I'm just going to drop it right here in the middle.
And this is our view.
So this is where we're going to make things look pretty.
And this is also where we can do stuff like this.
So here we go.
I've put this button over here.
Now, let's see that we wanted to add some text to this button.
Now, there's a couple of things that I could do.
I could take this text and I could also, you know, come here and try to place it on the button.
But this leads to a couple of problems.
So you can see here, that's not really ideal when I move that, it moves away.
So another cool thing is over here in the hierarchy, what we can do is we can take this text
and actually drop it on top of that button.
And now whenever I move this button, that text is going to come along for the ride.
Now, over here is the Details panel,
and this is going to be context sensitive based off of what I have selected.
So in this example, look, if I select the button here,
I have everything for the button, like its color and its style,
but I don't have access to the text.
What I have to do is come here and click on the text.
And now I can change this to maybe something like Start.
So there we go.
I have my Start button.
Now I can also do cool stuff like grab this button 25 and duplicate it.
So I could have this Start and then maybe I have this other one over here.
Maybe we call this one Quit.
So here we go, Q-U-I-T.
And there we go, we have our Start and our Quit.
Now, the other cool thing about the UMG tool,
again, is the event graph.
Now I'm going to grab this Quit button here and I'm just going to come over here
and we're going to scroll all the way down to this On Clicked
and we're going to hit this plus sign right there.
And notice that it's actually taking me over to the event graph.
And again, here's my designer and here is my graph.
Now the graph is what makes this functional.
So if I was just to come here and just do print, do a print string, we'll say hello.
Now I'm just going to compile and save this.
And I have it preset up so that when I go ahead and press play here,
you can see there's my start and my quit.
So if I hit quit, you can see it says hello.
And that's how easy things are to set up using UMG.
That's why this tool is so powerful,
because we can quickly set things up inside of our designer here,
give our buttons different functionalities by coming over here and with the events.
You can see here we have it On Clicked and On Pressed.
But even if I was to come here for maybe grab an analog slider here,
we can do something like grab this and say on analog begin mouse capture.
Let's do that.
We'll print to this string again and let's just compile and save.
And you'll see how simple it is to do stuff with this,
which is why this is such a powerful tool.
You can see it's saying hello right there.
So again, it's working just the way that we want it.
We also have the full access to the standard blueprint debugger
so we can see what's going on inside of here.
You can see the execution happening there.
So again, this is Unreal Motion Graphics and this tool is what we utilize
to help make our UI's both beautiful as well as interactive.